it was recently announced that galactus
and tyrant are going to be making their
way into the MCU how's it going
everybody it's Warren and this was
definitely insanely exciting good news
that Galactus is going to be the next
big bad of the MCU and that tyrant could
possibly come as early as phase four
tyrant could show up as early as the
Eternals movie beam Galactus is first
Herald and as far as when Galactus is
going to show up and why we're not sure
but there are a number of theories going
around right now that make a ton of
sense and right now one of the biggest
theories going around that actually
makes a lot of sense states that Thanos
actually created Galactus I'll break
down this theory and why it makes sense
in this video the first a quick reminder
if you'd like a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 be sure to subscribe to my
channel like the video and comment below
with your favorite superhero or villain
to enter my giveaway in the beginning of
Avengers endgame the Avengers went to go
and fight Thanos and which they defeated
him
but before they defeated the mad Titan
he mentioned that he used the stones to
destroy the stones he reduced them to
atoms he did this because his work was
done he had balanced the universe so
there was no more need for the stones
however what if he also did something
else with the second snap when he
destroyed the Infinity stones it's safe
to say that Fanus knew how the time
stone worked or at least could figure it
out and it's already been stated by the
Avengers endgame riders that Thanos
accepted his fate and let Thor kill him
again he had completed what he
considered his destiny balancing the
universe so all was done for him he
didn't mind dying because his work was
done and considering the fact that he
knew how to use the time stone he
probably went forward in time and saw
his own death he saw that the Avengers
would come for the stone so therefore he
destroyed them however Thanos is a
genius and is always one step ahead of
everybody and he wouldn't want anything
to be left to chance so what if he
created a back-up plan remember when you
use the time stone you can't see past
her own death we learned this in Doctor
Strange so Thanos could have saw the
Avengers coming for the stones but he
couldn't see anything past that so he
could have very well made a backup plan
in case the Avengers somehow managed to
undo his snap and that backup plan could
be in the form of a planet eating entity
called Galactus Galactus the Devourer of
worlds could be read Condon
MC you to be a creation of Thanos what
if dana says back-up plan is a cosmic
entity that would come in and consume
and destroy planets when their
populations become too abundant for
their resources and what if the reduced
atoms of the Infinity stones could
somehow be reformed into the power
cosmic using the power cosmic Galactus
can transform other beings into some of
the most powerful creations in the
cosmos the Silver Surfer for example and
tyrant who is mentioned to be coming
into the MC with Galactus this is a
really really interesting way to retcon
Galactus this story into the MCU and
have him tie into Thanos and the
Infinity Saga that way all the future
phases of the MCU still connect directly
with phase one two and three it has been
confirmed that Galactus is going to be
appearing in the MCU soon could Marvel
possibly tie Galactus to Thanos by
making Galactus Thanos's backup plan for
balance in the universe having Galactus
come in to consume and devour worlds
that grow too big for their resources if
they go this route it when it makes
sense for tyrant to appear in the
Eternals movie because the Eternals
takes place thousands of years before
the events of Avengers endgame but let
me know what you think about this theory
of Galactus being created by fan oohs as
sort of a back-up plan to come in and
devour worlds to keep the balance in the
universe let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and again don't
forget to comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU don't
forget to follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and of course as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof